does it surprise you what what people
grab onto for example not just the TV
stuff but um and I don't even know if
you are aware of it or maybe your kids
became aware of it but you you going
viral for falling off a stage oh yeah
this is a video clip that has like comes
the guy from Cheers the guy from Frasier
Sideshow Bob the guy from the stage yeah
yeah I mean it's going to happen
I was I was doing the 50th anniversary
show for Disney at Disneyland and there
was a stage although it was supported
though show Aladdin that they had at the
time and there were stars on the edge of
the stage which was sort of cut out so
the proscenium the stage part ended in
jagged edges on one side so I rehearse
tit with the lights on right and then
when I did the show there was just a
spotlight and it was dark so I lost
track of where the start edge of the
stage was you know so I stepped off a
new hit the point of one of those stars
scraped my leg from my knee all the way
up to ho my buttocks and it was not
pretty but I finished the show and then
I went to the hospital oh you did you go
to the hospital oh yeah Wow
no they said like I said this is worse
than any motorcycle accident I've seen
really yeah that's discursive but my I
wanted to be polite even so I said oh
dear Lord instead of you know what was
great though that was it made it was
show like there was so much glass right
in that dear Lord thing a true gentleman
I think the thing that snapped into my
mind was when my grandmother broke her
hip mm-hmm that was kind of the
beginning of the end for her and I
thought I'd broken my hip that's
actually that's what I thought and I
tried that tested it to see if I could
walk a little bit and I was okay and
you're like okay I'm all right
how long did it take you to get up and
get back on the stage there's about a
minute okay just kind of wasn't too long
I just had to test it do you believe
there your pants or anything yeah so you
were a lot on your pants and wow you are
a hardcore
show must go on exactly
no no subsequently I mean you know I see
that again I can see why people think
it's funny I mean I had a friend fall
off the stage before and I had a good
good giggle when it happened right here
old right off the hill what the hell
happened to Graham
he realized he was in the pit here's the
thing about stages that are so great is
that when somebody falls off you don't
actually see them fall did you just know
it's comical because it's instantly sort
of comical so yeah I certainly
understand it it was a very painful
moment for me in reality but I get the
irony of sure there's a friend of mine
named Keith Robinson and we have footage
from the comedy smell of him walking
onstage and tripping on his face or a
passed a piano it's literally the
greatest thing I've ever seen things are
fun I've watched ya and the falling it
is but it's a banana peel you know yeah
that's what it would never not be fun
yeah exactly
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]